we gave you a skirt is our story and the  big empty listen it doesn't matter you  two teams in the bottom a leg or a tough  lady thing atmosphere subclasses you to  stadium two magnificent four thousand  people stand on the fray and chair and  as professional sport you play football  for you wanna play in front of a big  crowd always exciting games every  weekend something happens so it's a  shock resort are some fantastic goals  atmosphere before a game during the game  after the game adjustment rid of it  everyone's grown up which independently  matter where the conformance for me is  potentially the best leverage of the  Barclays Premier Li the Etihad Emirates  studies objectors Park Casey steady of  the father's to Old Trafford a pair